this is a pepper panic saga level 212
walkthrough tutorial video
it is i'm going to play through the
level to complete it and i'm going to
explain
why i do what i do as i go
this was
this was probably the most difficult
level in the most recent episode
pepper panic saga episode 15.
and
it can basically be impossible if you
can't remove these top statues up here
so
a lot of times if you can't make make a
match
up here to open this up
or you don't have anything down here
that can send the shock wave up
you might be better off just to hit the
quit button over here and just
go ahead and
start over
there are scenarios where you can you
know make some matches down here clear
out these statues and send shock waves
up but it's really
difficult that way
and
with 45 moves i mean you can really
spend a lot of time
in a hopeless situation which can make
you frustrated
so here i i i have a nice set up in the
beginning i have an l-shaped match and
um i'll go ahead and make that then i'll
knock out this
and what that'll do is is allow
peppers to fall into the top so that i
can get the rest of these statues
okay so
you know ideally you'd want to get one
on this side too
but
you're probably not going to
get that to happen
very often so
just keep in mind that you can still
complete it even if this doesn't happen
you're going to get some timers that are
going to turn to stone here but you're
basically going to have to try to set up
a shock wave in this row right here
to get that going
so
um
you can uh
you can watch these timer like over here
we can't match any of these anyways
these these two we can match together
but there's 15 and 14 on them so we
don't want to waste the move yet so um
because if we if we explode a purple
pepper pepper in the process then
they'll just get wiped out anyways
so i'm going to make matches at the
bottom now i'm going to try to get rid
of these statues hit these statues as i
go
and overall just try to set up a shock
wave in this row
or column i should say
that's really the most important thing
because if we never get rid of one of
these statues then we can't complete the
level so everything else is just
um
you know not as important
and you know some of these things will
pick up naturally as we go we'll hit
these statues sometimes we'll get rid of
these statues a lot of the time
so really
all your folks should be on opening up
the side you didn't get
there i could have made it a t-shaped it
really wouldn't have accomplished much
so what i did instead was try to um
grow the purple
and
that'll get rid of these
timers up here
and if it starts pepper panic it'll
hit these statues and it'll also remove
all the other tiners that have been
grown past stage one so that
you'll see after this that's a pretty
good
deal because now we don't have anything
in our way from hitting these statues
so this is where you have to to really
think you you know
this is a small space it's one column
only that you can actually use and so
you're gonna have to
kind of struggle through this it's not a
very easy thing to do
the matches i made so far i made so i
could have my gap here but
getting another blue pepper in line
isn't going to be easy
and we'll probably also run into a
situation where we have to match these
if we run out of moves elsewhere
i'm basically just trying to make
matches in ways that'll
clear out space
as things fall
all right so that's what we were trying
to set up we got it
we'll take that shot
and now
now things change now we just basically
want to
chip away at these statues
and then um
you know pick up these statues at the
top when we get a chance
we have yellow and green sitting on top
here so that's not
there's no real um
sometimes if you have both of the same
color up there that'd be nice to
blow up those but for the most part
we're just going to make big matches and
we're going to try to send shock waves
at these we got 27 moves left so we're
in a pretty good spot
there's nothing real great down here so
you know the um
you could go after this purple here to
take this out but because the the
trap doors are still blocked so this
won't really fall
but um
that's actually a lot easier than
than taking out these at this point so
i'm not really going to worry about that
at the moment
oops
right now i'm basically just trying to
grow green so that i can switch things
up down here and then also maybe take
out the top statue on this side
purple's looking a little bit better now
based on where it's at
but now that that opened up that changes
things but just watch and see um see how
we just we picked up that statue anyway
so there really was no no reason to go
out of our way for it
and the same thing will happen on this
side as well
you could try to plan you know based on
the trapdoor
how this is going to go down
but overall like i said you'll you'll
pick it up as you go
i'm looking for shock waves to hit this
one and when they're not available i'm
just growing the green to
take out this last statue on this side
all right so we got that one
so we kind of took care of everything
that was was really hard now we have 20
moves to get an explosion up here by
these guys
let's see
i'm gonna clear this column and see if
more green fall
because you can see there's no greens
over here so these greens are gonna stay
in place
and
um once that's gone
that actually makes this a lot easier
because these peppers don't drop over
here
so now we have three different colors
sitting there um
we'll just
we'll just have to grow and then see
which ones uh
what what opportunities come up
right now green or purple are both good
there's one green one in here
so there really won't slide the middle
really won't slide that much different
but with blue it would so we don't
really want to mess with the blue ones
as much
a little bit stuck here
this is kind of
jumbled up at the bottom
but that'll do it
so it's definitely a challenging level
it's not easy by any stretch of the
imagination but if you approach it in
that way
you should be able to beat it
um i don't i wouldn't say consistently
but um
you know one of the major things to keep
in mind there is is
the top part you need to open that up
and if you don't i'm sure you pro if
you're watching this video you've
probably already been stuck at the
bottom with nothing going on i mean you
can literally sit there
and play out all 45 moves without a good
shot at getting at those statues at the
top
once the peppers turn petrified you just
won't get that many good opportunities
to get all the way up through the top
so um this will be going along with our
full guide and um
you should definitely read that
if you got any questions leave comments
be sure to like us on facebook and i
hope this video helps so that you can
get through the level thanks